all right so we're continuing to follow
the truly malignant growth
of the coronavirus anti-vaccine movement
and i have some really stunning video to
show you today
uh this is real video of a hearing in
ohio about a bill which would ban
any ohio business or school from
mandating
covet vaccination this looks like a
satirical show when you watch it it
actually looks like an episode of judge
judy or something
uh or or a saturday night live parody
of judge judy but it's sadly real
here you are going to see sherry 10
penny
who goes by doctor now she is an
osteopathic physician
i don't want to get into a whole thing
about md
versus do she is a do
let's not even really touch that right
now because i will get a lot of hate and
furious people
let's simply say there are lots of
reasonable dos without question
there are also just tons and tons
of nutty osteopathic doctors including
quack chiropractors and anti-vaccine
nuts and all sorts of different stuff
we're just going to focus on sherry 10
penny here
sherry 10 penny spent much of this
hearing saying
we really shouldn't live in fear of
coronavirus but then
she shows up and spreads insane
irrational fears
about vaccines take a look at this first
video clip
thinking if there is a if you can think
of any other product in any other
industry
that has killed more than 5 000 people
stated in the verse database
and even if only half of those are true
200
2500 deaths in six months of use
and it's still full court press full
steam ahead
so it makes one have to wonder why why
are we still doing this why are we
putting people into nursing homes like
that happened in new york
and put people with with known covet
into place so
she first testified stop living in fear
of covet there's too much fear people
are too afraid
and then she says you really should be
afraid of that vaccine that vaccine is
actually something to really be afraid
of
and then it truly went off the rails
with 10 penny
claiming that there is metal in the
vaccine
which causes forks to stick to your
forehead
she saw a video about that on the
internet and then she also
just ties in some conspiracies
conspiracies about 5g
cell phone networks so let's hear from
dr sherry 10 penny
and some of the information that i think
had been discussed on your podcast
related to emf
frequencies that was a thought and and
it was
because now because right now we're all
kind of hypothesizing i mean what is it
that's actually being transmitted
that's causing all of these things is it
a combination of the protein which now
we're finding has a metal attached to it
i'm sure you've seen the pictures all
over the internet
of people who've had these shots and now
they're magnetized they put a key on
their forehead it sticks they can put
spoons and forks all over them and they
can stick
because now we think that there's a
metal piece to that there's been people
who've long suspected that there was
some sort of an interface
yet to be defined an interface between
what's being injected in these shots
and all of the 5g towers not proven yet
but we're trying to figure out what is
it that's being transmitted to these
unvaccinated people
how insane is this stuff how this really
should make us scared
about the future of this country it is
shocking that
this person was able to become a doctor
of osteopathy
i have a hard time understanding how she
even accomplishes simple things like
how does she go grocery shopping if her
view of the world is this ridiculous how
does she how did she drive a car to this
hearing
quite frankly later on uh one of the
committee members
asked 10 penny this hearing was in ohio
remember
uh dr 10 penny how many people in ohio
uh where the hearing is being conducted
have died from
being vaccinated against covid check out
how that went
um for the record if i missed it
here or there um of the five and a half
million ohioans who have gotten the
coven 19 shot through today over the
last six months how many do you believe
have been killed by that shot
well um i guess i could i could just
talk to you
so um i don't know okay so she's not
sure
she's not sure how many people died from
the vaccine
in ohio all right is it out of line to
say
that if she truly believes this stuff
she should be evaluated for
delusions psychosis paranoid
schizophrenia like is it
i'm not i'm not joking about mental
illness
is it out of line to ask that how is she
testifying
as an expert on anything never mind
vaccines
so what's happening here to give you a
little background on the bill
is that republicans in ohio in the state
general assembly want to weaken
ohio's vaccination laws for all vaccines
not just for covet 19.
so this was a hearing about house bill
248
and the legislation would ban vaccine
requirements on customers
employees or students from businesses
hospitals nursing homes k-12 schools
colleges day cares or others it would
also
prevent government insurers or
businesses
from offering incentives for people to
get vaccinated
or even requesting that people get
vaccinated so it's an outrageous bill
and again remember they want to be about
we don't want regulation
except we're going to say businesses
would be outlawed
from even encouraging employees
to go and get themselves vaccinated it's
absolutely bonkers and the ohio capital
journal points out that
under the bill if you are an
asthmatic small business owner for
example
uh meaning you are at significantly
higher risk of complications from
covid19
you would have no legal right to require
or even ask that your employees or
customers that come in
be vaccinated you're a small business
owner republicans are all about
hey we're for business we're against
regulation let these small business
owners do what they want to do
they would prevent you this law would
prevent you from even saying because of
my
status health-wise i am requesting not
even necessarily mandating i am
requesting that my employees or my
customers be vaccinated
so this is an absolute disaster
that they are going in this direction
and look at the people who are
testifying here i mean it is depressing
that these are folks who are
increasingly uh having having an impact
and
uh having a say and if you didn't see if
you just listened
watch the videos you see people sitting
in the crowd sort of nodding as dr 10
penny says these wacky wacky things
it is depressing to see one of our
sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches
and identity theft and it's free and
like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman